more than two months into the war in
ukraine and both sides are taking heavy
losses while the bombardment goes on
moscow has kept up its relentless
propaganda accusing nato of conducting a
proxy war with russia
my guest this week is lecia vasilenko
politician and human rights lawyer who
joins me from kiev what makes her so
sure mr putin wouldn't press his nuclear
button in all honesty putin has made so
many claims which
which he never went ahead with
saying that he is willing to deploy
nuclear weapons in ukraine would be
suicidal to him and to his own country
and his own people as well in recent
weeks she's had blunt words for the west
and nato accusing the alliance of
cowardice and watching the war as if it
were a movie does she still feel that
way
and what about a future peace deal with
russia is there any sign at all of what
it might look like
all that and much more on conflict zone
[Music]
lesia vasilenko welcome to conflict zone
thank you it's a pleasure to be here
more than two months into this war some
five million of your people have left as
refugees but now hundreds of thousands
are coming back sometimes against the
advice of local authorities what does
that tell you about your people your
country it's a resilient and stubborn
people
that russia has to deal with and we are
very confident in our victory and very
confident in the victory of freedom and
independence
and the people who you are seeing coming
back are the people who more than
anything want to live in a free and
independent ukraine and are prepared to
do everything to rebuild it from the
wrath of russia's aggression we've seen
ukrainians forced to confront
unbelievable pain and loss almost on a
daily basis some have spoken in
interviews about their
continuing disbelief at what's happening
to them do you share that feeling every
single ukrainian has lost something in
this war
uh the worst is people having to endure
losses of close ones like family members
and dear friends
people have lost
property have lost
houses homes
everyone's at a loss
why it happened
because of russia we know it very
clearly now
how it was
possible to even
go as far as the russians did with all
the crimes they are committing currently
in the territory of ukraine this is
something unfaithful this is something
that
many ukrainians myself included still
cannot puzzle together what have you
learned about yourself
during this period
oh a lot i think that myself like many
other ukrainian women we uncovered the
strengths that we never knew we had
before
uh
this these past two months on the bed
have been about unity and have been
about resilience for every single person
for every single family in ukraine
we have discovered all myself included
that we are a strong people
we are a nation a united nation and a
nation that really really loves its
country and is prepared to die for it
and the knowledge as you say prepared to
die for it but the knowledge that life
could end today tonight tomorrow for you
and those who you care about
is that an ever-present feeling and does
that
sap your focus or does it
in a way
inspire you i've learned to live with it
personally
and so have millions of ukrainians who
remained in ukraine
it's a it's a strange feeling that you
know that it can all end tomorrow but um
i think the fear of losing
freedom and losing life in the free
ukraine losing the home is greater than
the fear of losing your own life you
mentioned the crimes that are being
committed and you've been keeping track
of some of the war crimes allegations
that have been piling up against russian
forces especially when it comes to the
the treatment of women and girls how
shocking has that been for you
that is exactly what my mind cannot put
together the puzzle piece pieces are
there right in front of me on the table
with the facts of the
rapes committed against ukrainian women
ukrainian children ukrainian unarmed men
uh i have the facts of numerous tortures
they're all there laid out on the table
sometimes with absolutely devastating
pictures to go with them
but
my brain cannot process the cruelty
behind it the intent and the violence
and
this is this is the restlessness with
which i also had to learn to live with
the restlessness of the brain which then
leads to many sleepless nights do you
believe that russian commanders have
ordered these crimes that are alleged to
have been committed or simply turned a
blind eye to them i believe that it's a
strategy of the russian army as well as
of the leadership of russia as a country
to destroy ukraine and ukrainians in
every way possible what the russians are
doing is is more than just physically
killing ukrainian soldiers
they are trying to erase the ukrainian
nation from the face of the earth and
they are doing this in so many different
ways
uh the fact that our children today for
more than two months
have been uh deprived of proper
education the schools are closed the
kindergartens are closed the
universities are closed all across
ukraine there's only online schooling uh
the children are
not in schools learning new things not
socializing with their kids but they are
hiding in bomb shelters they are in the
basements hiding from russian artillery
and from russian soldiers who are
hunting them down to kill them to
torture them to rape them
and this is a future generation of
ukrainians which will be growing up with
huge traumas
and with uh very very limited education
and learning skills
this is ukraine we are talking about a
european nation which has prided itself
for years in the number of literate
people literate children of the
successes educational successes of the
children in schools and russia is taking
that away they are destroying that
deliberately what about the chances of
bringing winnable prosecutions against
any of the soldiers that have been
committing these acts so far i believe
10 have been identified as suspects from
the unit that occupied butcher where the
bodies of civilians apparently shot in
summary executions were left lying in
the streets do you have any hope that
that these people might be brought to
trial might be brought to justice i'm
confident that justice will be served
will be served in the ukrainian courts
and the within the ukrainian justice
system it will be served in uh
international judicial bodies such as
the international criminal court
international court of justice and i
firmly believe that eventually the world
will set up a special criminal tribunal
for putin all his crownies all the
generals and all the soldiers who have
been committing war crimes in ukraine
talk to me if you will about
life under occupation in kursan for
instance
is there anything in russia's behavior
there that allow you to form any view of
their
long-term aims the russians long-term
aims i gather the mayor has been
replaced the currency is being replaced
with russian rubles reports that russian
textbooks have been brought into schools
that the internet has been disconnected
and connect reconnected to moscow's own
system is is this the template as far as
you're concerned preparations
being made for permanent occupation of
the places where they are at the moment
it looks like it i mean you asked me a
couple of questions back about whether
there's a fear about dying and i've said
to you that there's a fear about losing
this freedom you can rephrase it by
saying that the fear of living under
such conditions that you have just
described or occupied her son where uh
you you just don't
lose everything like physically because
your home is destroyed but
you can you are told how to live
you are
being deprived of information channels
you are being deprived of the language
of your history of your currency even
and you are being told that this is it
this is how you live now you have no
choice and i think this is the worst
fear that every ukrainian has
and for us here son militopol mariupol
they are all the cities which epitomize
what the russians are trying to impose
on all of ukraine and again this gets
the ukrainian nation even more united
and even more determined to fight even
harder what's the role of a of a
politician like you under these
circumstances what what can you do for
your constituents how do you even keep
track of the of the
living and the dead uh today it's much
easier than back in the day i imagine
because of the social media and because
everybody literally has uh devices with
internet and can can
do a wider outreach and this is how we
learn today of the needs of the people
the role of politicians is to be here on
the ground with the people of ukraine
supporting them liaising them with the
partners the international partners who
can provide assistance and who can
provide relief to the various needs
and we're talking about basic needs here
we're talking about getting food to
people medicine care for the sick and
elderly that sort of thing humanitarian
aid absolutely if you want one word for
it how and at what level do do the
mechanics of daily life continue though
under this constant bombardment actually
now it has become more or less
back to normal if you like
i'm talking now from downtown here i see
in the street a lot of cars a lot of
people passing by the shops are reopened
the cafes are reopened nevertheless we
have uh
air race sirens sounding from time to
time and we learn to live with it in the
background uh and we learn to to to make
best of it and every single person has
found a
space uh
in their life for volunteer work for
helping others who are worse off than
they are and the same goes for
parliamentarians politicians for
government officials apart from our
regular duties about writing laws
debating them in parliament voting on
them discussing them in committees we
find a lot of space and a lot of time
for uh coordinating volunteer work for
coordinating humanitarian aid for
coordinating uh military assistance uh
to to the different territorial defense
units and to the different uh military
units even so
everybody's doing that [ __ ] to keep
ukraine safe to keep the community safe
and at the end of the day to keep their
families and themselves safe
you said recently that 80 percent of
your thoughts are directed at the now
the war but 20 is thinking about the
future and about reconstruction how
vital is that from a practical point of
view and i suppose from the point of
view of morale as well
uh it's absolutely important to look to
the future
uh to know your past and to act in the
present so of course the conditions are
such today that we have to concentrate
on the present to survive
and that's that's the main thing but
then again we're talking about people
coming back to ukraine we're talking
about people coming back to find
destruction uh in the towns that have
been occupied by russia and have been
freed by ukraine and these towns need
rebuild this is just a simple example as
that and to rebuild them there needs to
be a vision of rebuilding there needs to
be a plan like there was a marshall plan
for europe there must be a certain plan
for ukraine today we call it the
brussels plan because essentially it's
the eu institutions which have come
forward and which have started to device
uh devise a certain scheme as to how to
renew ukraine and how much money needs
to be allocated to the uk although
already not part of the eu but the uk is
playing a big role as well there is a
whole team of british economists which
is now working
with ukrainian specialists and experts
to also devise a plan of economic
recovery which would touch also on the
energy sector on the agricultural sector
on the industrial and trading sectors so
work is being done
but of course the ukrainian counterparts
cannot dedicate 100
of time to that work
mrs vasilenko on the political front
you've recently been very critical of
the un secretary general antonio
gutierrez because he went to moscow a
few days ago before going to kiev what
did he bring back from russia anything
that your government thought was worth
listening to
he brought back a missile attack on the
building in kiev
which was destroyed and several people
died from from that missile attack and
a 10 or so were
injured and taken to hospital with heavy
wounds
apart from that
not much
has resulted
not really his fault though
not not really his fault no but uh you
know uh the point is that uh i think the
he uh and this is the point that i tried
to make many many times is that the u.n
needs reform
the u.n as a system has failed has
failed big time to prevent wars in the
past and to prevent this war of russia's
aggression which has been going on for
eight years now russia staying on the
security council having veto power is
absolute nonsense i mean russia is
responsible for the insecurity in the
world and the instability in the world
today and they are there making security
decisions
uh we have as ukrainians time and time
again raise the issue about the reform
of the of the un system we were not hurt
um
then when we have the secretary general
first going to moscow and then coming to
q
that also doesn't make sense why go and
do pay the respects and the jews to the
aggressive us come come to ukraine see
what russia has done and then go to
putin with the demands not the other way
around this was the point i was trying
to make but okay to be fair to be fair
uh after the secretary general's visit
the evacuation of the people from other
style and other styles still works in uh
in mario paul has started
uh and has had many successes so i'm
grateful for that i would love to
believe that it's because there was
these negotiations with the un secretary
general involved if that is the case
then with great gratitude and great
respect i say thank you to the u.n
secretary general
along with other ukrainian mps you've
spent some time shuttling between
western capitals explaining ukraine's
position its requirements its views and
especially its suffering and you've
heard a lot of overarching expressions
of solidarity and promises of full
support but you haven't been that
impressed with them have you a lot of
them
ah not with all of them uh words are
words and what words are important uh
the solidarity messages they are well
received here in ukraine they also allow
the ukrainian people to go on for so
long because knowing that there's this
unfeeling this immense support from
every single country in europe but
almost every single country in europe on
the continent
was a great push for the ukrainians to
keep going to know that we're not alone
in this and to know that the big
european family in to which we we strive
so much is there with us that's
important but of course uh what i would
like to see more of is that these words
would be backed up by action
and we are slowly getting there so
ukraine is getting more weapons and
ukraine uh is is getting more help in
terms of humanitarian financial
assistance and russia is getting more
and more sanctions uh around it and
these sanctions are becoming more robust
the only thing is that uh
it would have been better for everyone's
sake not just for ukraine if all of this
was happening faster and a couple of
months back
but in time a few weeks ago you accused
western countries of doing the bare
minimum and standing on the sidelines
watching ukraine as if it was a boxing
match or a tv documentary you've changed
your views since then there's a lot more
than the bare minimum isn't there
uh you know today when uh i i see the
lists of the weapons which are being
delivered by the western allies and when
i know for a fact from reports of uh the
military units that i know personally
that these weapons get to that uh
to to where they're supposed to get and
they are being used for good use uh
then i i have no reason to be unhappy
about it i mean these weapons and this
support the main ideas for it to keep
coming until the plague of russia's
aggression is stopped and returned back
into the uh within the borders of russia
you wanted a no-fly zone you didn't get
it do you want nato troops fighting
alongside you in
in ukraine
well that would be always the preferred
option
uh but you understand why they're not
at the same time you know although
that's always the preferred option the
more we have uh allied powers here side
to side with us uh fighting for freedom
and for democracy and for peace in the
world the better but uh at the same time
uh ukrainian army has proven itself to
be absolutely self-sustainable when it
comes to fighting of the russians as
long as we have the means to fight us
and if the nato powers and the
international community provides us with
those instruments provides us with those
weapons and the almonds then we're good
to go we can withstand russia's
aggression we can keep fighting for the
rest of europe we can be the protectors
of europe while protecting of course our
thousand our freedom at the same time
but uh when putin has openly referred to
his nuclear arsenal and has put it he
says on a higher state of alert you
wouldn't expect the west and nato in
particular not to take that threat
seriously would you
um
in all honesty putin has made so many
claims which
which he never went ahead with saying
that he is willing to deploy nuclear
weapons in ukraine would be suicidal to
him and to his own country and his own
people as well and it's a good thing
that it's not just him alone putin alone
who's in charge of pressing that one red
button there's a whole line of command
to start deploying nuclear weapons and
in all honesty if putin has gone
completely insane which is clearly the
case uh not all of his generals and not
all of the people in the line of command
in moscow have gone as badly and same as
to wish death upon themselves and their
families
do you still think that the un and nato
as you said in a tweet on march the 13th
are showing weakness and cowardice
as i said the un needs reforming and
very fast
uh
nato nato is nato i mean in
all fairness nato is abiding by the by
the walls in their rulebook
uh fair enough
uh but at the same time the different
nato states are showing more uh more
confidence and more courage uh and then
that whole organization put together
and i think this is the courage that
ukrainians expect from their partners
you know now there's a snap line going
around saying be brave like ukraine
and this is what we want from our
friends
but cowardice is a is perhaps an unfair
criticism isn't it
an unfair criticism of what
of nato and the u.n
well look the un is an organization has
uh deep structural problems
i've covered already the ground about
russia being
a country with a veto power on the
security council being responsible for
the insecurity the u.n could have sent
peacekeeping troops into ukraine through
a general assembly decision it hasn't
done so for fear of provoking world war
iii but in all honesty putin would never
dare to attack any other country for the
very reason that he has no resources for
doing that and for the very reason that
he's concentrated on ukraine and maybe a
couple of other eastern european
countries because putin his goal is to
rebuild a russian empire this is the
ideology behind this war this is the
ideology behind how russia functions as
a country
they want an empire they feel great in
an empire they want to bring empires in
the worst possible sense back from the
history books this is what they are
doing they are not interested in going
ahead with wars in i don't know asia
africa or the americas because they they
they would not be able to to pull it off
and when the world stands united in the
same way that ukrainians stood united
against putin there would be nothing
that he could do this war could have
stopped
way way earlier the three days that the
international experts were giving us uh
as a nation for standing up against the
second largest army in the world could
have been really three days to end this
war if
uh
nato forces u.n forces would have
intervened in time this war could have
been over
in three days but it could have been
over for russia in three days
there are plenty of western experts
who'd dispute your assurance that putin
would never press the button and use his
nuclear missiles but i want in in the
time we have left to
look at where the war might go now
a month ago president zielenski said
that negotiation was the only way out of
the conflict
but he added you cannot just demand from
ukraine to recognize some territories as
independent republics these compromises
are simply wrong we have to come up with
a model where ukraine will not lose its
sovereignty and its in its territorial
integrity do you have any idea what
that model might look like
that model is very simple
i mean uh russia is committing a crime a
crime of aggression there's no doubt
about that i think it's very much clear
for all of the international community
what russia is doing
that crime of aggression has clear
criteria as described in a number of
conventions and with that uh there's
also consequences
which pertain to when a crime of
aggression is committed and the
consequences are such that first of all
the crime must be stopped hence russia
must retreat all of its troops from
ukraine
the borders of ukraine must be
reinstated and then russia must pay
reparations it's as simple as that
there's no other negotiations that can
be taking place any negotiations
where ukraine is presumably
requested to give up any territories or
to make any kind of other concessions to
russia will fail these negotiations will
not bring long-standing peace to ukraine
to europe to the world these
kind of secession negotiations will only
incite
more aggression in the world it will
inspire
uh other
authoritarian leaders across the world
to follow in putin's footsteps and they
will inspire putin to go in for more
land groups the only solution is to make
russia stop its crime of aggression
to restore the territorial integrity of
ukraine and to make russia pay for all
the crimes that it has committed in the
territory of ukraine and for the crime
of aggression against international
peace and security
vasilenko it's been very good to have
you on conflict zone thank you very much
indeed thank you
thank you it was a pleasure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you